let's talk about just our Wars is the
big everyone's talking about Star Wars
the movie comes out tomorrow night
you must've been a perfect age when that
when that film came out
I don't somehow I missed that movie when
it came out like I grew I grew up like
isolated in a weird way we lived on a
busy street so we were cut off from the
other kids and I remember I remember
that school year in June I could talk to
somebody my age and then over the summer
Star Wars came out and by September I
didn't know what anybody was talking
about they all talking about the force
in Chewbacca and all of that you hadn't
seen it no I did I never thought I saw
it later by the time then I was too old
and I was like this is like a cheesy
self-help book put in outer space with
like the Muppets I don't I don't get it
I don't get what I missed it you got to
be a kid right you guys all saw when you
were kids yeah yeah I didn't you didn't
see it I had perspective like I saw it
when I was like 27 I'm so glad it's all
right crazy I just want to drive by that
line but yeah we're all standing and
yeah like why does it matter
why is it this important that's they're
happy they're happy why should we but
you can tell much money that movie's
gonna make everybody's just staring at
me I don't care I just you know okay
when I saw these our first three movies
I saw I saw for the love of Benji then
we saw Herbie goes to Monte Carlo yeah
and then we saw Scarface it went right
off the rail parents took you to see
Scarface how old were you guys I was
like 13 my youngest brother was like
seven she didn't know what it was
she thought it she know was like a
gangster movie but she thought I was
like you know like Kojak or something
like TV show so she took your
nine-year-old brother and you shadows
911 all of it whatever to go see
Scarface and why didn't she when it got
started that's the point where you say
oh because there's stuff going down in
that movie within 30 seconds so Megan
yeah the Megan's chain saw it first five
minutes that's right and if she wanted
to leave then I would have but she
didn't she just is very reserved she's
kind of like this is maybe this will get
better like she's just
does that thing she's she's very like my
dad was the volatile one my mother was
always just like he's he's in a mood
yeah yeah no one's ever said that about
that character yeah he's in a mood